I'm no stranger to being critiqued and
confronted even trolled online but when
it comes from a fellow medical colleague
I tend to take it a little bit more to
heart because I want medical colleagues
to be able to criticize me and for us to
create better information I think this
is a group effort when it comes to
educating people online but when it
comes from a place of toxicity that's
when it becomes problematic let's first
watch the clip that caused the
controversy different traumas can
actually show up as physical ailments
later in life what how do you work
through that then well first you have to
be honest and do a proper work up and
make sure it's not anatomical your
proper history have to do a physical
exam we have to get an Imaging to make
sure there's nothing going on
anatomically again there's no tear
there's no and then you see if the
patient is open to it you have to say
hey I think that I've ruled out
everything anatomically that could be
wrong and I'm thinking that this is real
you are feeling this I'm not saying this
is in your head the root cause is is
coming from something mental health
related do you want to try and talk
about that and if they're open to it we
do it and it works wow and what controls
the volume of the pain is our mental
health the initial feedback was very
positive people started talking about
how their experiences were shaped by
their mental health how their pain was
impacted by things going on inside their
minds or within their lives and I
thought great we accomplished two goals
here we had a short form piece of
content performed very well and then we
were also able to educate a million
people plus then started coming to
controversy as with any piece of content
that gets wide distribution now the
negativity was about people saying that
I'm a Doctor Who's now gaslighting his
patients and saying that there is
nothing wrong with them this is all made
up in their minds which goes exactly the
opposite as to what I was saying in this
clip this is real you are feeling this
I'm not saying this is in your head I
saw a comment appear from a verified
physician colleague of mine an
orthopedic surgeon a do and I was
curious about their take on this matter
because I always loved learning from
other doctors especially sub-specialists
who are experts in this field but I was
sad to see that the comment that was
left by this physician States why do so
many people take medical advice from a
pediatrician when the topics have
nothing to do with Pediatrics hashtag
clickbait
I honestly haven't been as confused in
reading a comment I'm not a pediatrician
this really has nothing to do with
Pediatrics this person came in again and
said in general there's a lot of medical
information about topics he and others
aren't experts about it would be like me
as an orthopedic surgeon giving info on
a Cardiology subject I'm not the person
for that info they rightfully go and
correct themselves and say ah right
family doctor again each specialty
should stay in their Lane Orthopedics is
not his Lane that's an orthopedic
surgeon's Lane he is assuming the
musculoskeletal pain is a mental health
issue when he isn't an expert in
musculoskeletal conditions now obviously
I get upset reading this I work with
orthopedic surgeons I've trained on
orthopedic surgeons I had a focus on
Sports Medicine preparing to become a
sports medicine fellow after Family
Medicine but all the Social Media stuff
got in the way so I have a lot of
experience treating musculoskeletal
conditions and to see a fellow Ortho say
that no one else is an expert on
musculoskeletal conditions except them
made me feel upset
because it's inaccurate I went on and
clicked on this person's name and wanted
to see if they've ever messaged me
before
lo and behold they messaged me before
and the message from a few years ago
States love what you are doing brother
I'm a fellow do and an orthopedic
surgeon if there's anything I can do for
you ever answer an orthopedic question
for you for any of the projects you're
working on Etc please let me know oh man
what happened in the few short years
that this person loved what I was doing
all of these things and now is so
critical for another doctor to publicly
call out a fellow colleague and then
generalize against all the other
colleagues as well they must see
something malicious in the intent of the
content that they're posting on and I
didn't feel like what I was posting was
malicious let alone even controversial
pain medicine organizations Ortho
organizations physical medicine and
rehabilitation organizations stand by
these principles that mental health
plays a role in physical health and that
we need to be more cognizant of it in
fact what we do wrong as Physicians is
oftentimes times write off mental health
so I respectfully said hey Doc I saw
your comment on my latest video Curious
what part you felt was inaccurate this
doctor writes back while I'm an
orthopedic surgeon so I look at it with
a different perspective I specialize in
lower extremities but I take care of a
lot of professional athletes in general
but say I see someone with a shoulder
issue that I can't quite put my finger
on despite my exam and imaging doesn't
always give you a clear answer either
all day I see athletes with normal MRIs
but have a musculoskeletal issue I don't
at that point assume it's a psychiatric
issue I assume that I'm missing the
diagnosis at which point I will send to
my colleague who is an expert in
shoulder issues and professional
athletes if he can't figure it out which
I would say between us both would be
exceedingly uncommon then maybe we
consider psychosocial issues ETC but
again of all the thousands of patients
we see it's less than 0.5 percent now
maybe psychiatric issues like depression
Etc can complicate the issue in regards
to pain tolerance it's not that the
actual musculoskeletal pathology G is
not real I think uh my fellow colleagues
respond here brings up a few points one
our patient population is very different
this person treats pro athletes I treat
real people the rate at which legendary
running back Adrian Peterson heals won't
be the same rate that I heal or one of
my patients who has heart disease or
diabetes the way that they experience
symptoms is going to be different they
need to be able to deliver a fastball a
hundred miles an hour with millimeter
accuracy my patient needs to be able to
type at a desk without experiencing high
levels of pain and while my Orthopedic
colleague here thinks that I'm
diagnosing this as a psychiatric issue
what I'm saying is psychosomatic issues
which is the medical term for this can
raise the volume of symptoms it's not
saying there's no pathology and if our
mental health State isn't clear if we're
dealing with something if we have
traumas that have been unaddressed these
are not necessarily psychiatric
diagnosis but these mental health
conditions lead us to experience pain
worse than what the anatomical condition
or pathology is there's actually a book
on this called the body keeps the score
that talks about how adverse childhood
events that Trauma from our childhood
can actually leave physical symptoms in
our bodies into adulthood I didn't say
that I don't involve Specialists I
didn't say that I don't get a second
opinion in fact if a patient still
thinks that there's something
anatomically going on or we're not just
getting a clear diagnosis that I'm
comfortable with we absolutely continue
finding what the cause is I even pointed
out in my response message that we can
disagree on how often mental health is a
leading or contributing factor to the
symptom of pain but is it necessary to
put down a fellow do and say
inflammatory lines like stay in your
lane he did offer to remove his comment
if he was offending me and that was nice
I had a genuine question for this
physician should only cardiologists talk
about high blood pressure because they
are the experts of the heart who is the
expert who is allowed to talk on it he
States it's a good question because even
in some Specialties like Ortho there are
docs who don't have enough knowledge to
speak on certain subjects and this
includes me so I don't give advice on it
I would guess it's an individual
decision and you would hope it would be
based on what the doctor feels
comfortable with problem is these days
social media people just want to talk
about stuff just for the hell of it to
get clicks not saying that this is what
you do no my friend that's exactly what
you said I do you wrote hashtag
clickbait on my post and we couldn't
really find a moment to agree on except
when he said that he actually liked what
I was saying and he would eventually use
the same approach with patients in the
future it really ended up getting
confusing and all of that is to say one
thing we need to do better as Physicians
as medical professionals communicating
online what I'd like to see happen is
how Dr Rena Malik critiqued me and
communicated with me after seeing a clip
of mine from the very same interview
about testosterone now Dr Arena Malik
didn't just leave a random negative
potentially even toxic comment under the
video she messaged me privately saying
hey Mike letting you know recent data
shows that there is no evidence of
increased cardiovascular risk with trt
and the original study data that was
popularized was actually Incorrect and
later corrected but still got propagated
through the medical community blood
clots yes not heart attacks I was so
happy that she sent this I love to get
critiqued challenged by my colleagues I
want to get better as a doctor I want to
do the right thing and put out accurate
info in fact I've made mistakes before
I've even shared that in a whole video
so here I understood where Dr Rita Malik
was coming right away testosterone
replacement therapy is used for patients
who have low testosterone for whatever
reason there's multiple reasons when I
asked Harry this he said that he is on
trt and my doctor was like Hey like your
test levels are fine you could be better
let's juice me up this is
steroid use this is not trt it's using
testosterone to create what we call
Supra physiological levels of
testosterone mean higher than normal so
the risks are not going to be the same
as trt this is why I began to explain to
Harry jowsy the risks of using
testosterone when you don't need it like
heart disease like infertility and
pointed out those issues and I needed to
confirm that I was thinking correctly so
I asked Dr Malik who is a urologist and
I said but what about testosterone use
above normal because what he's doing is
not trt it's more like steroid use and I
pointed out an article from the National
Institute of Health that shows using
steroids to get higher levels of
testosterone will create heart disease
she goes yes in Supra physiologic levels
but she is worried that people who are
truly low testosterone which she calls
calls hypogonadal and they're trying to
be you gonadal meaning they're restoring
their normal level of testosterone would
see this video and be worried and I said
that could be a problem and I probably
should leave a note in the video to make
sure that I'm clear in what I'm
communicating and she agreed that it is
nuanced thank you Dr Malik for
correcting me where I could have done
better but for not resorting to toxicity
online because that wouldn't help anyone
so I updated my caption on Instagram
based on Dr Malik's advice and we came
together and ultimately made a better
piece of content to educate others about
unnecessary steroid use and that's the
goal of communicating online as
Physicians do not seek to destroy and
always look for nuance because Nuance is
a superpower just like Jonathan Heights
said on this channel very engaging work
worthwhile conversation author of the
coddling of the American mind definitely
check this out as always stay happy and
healthy and don't leave toxic comments
[Music]